I'm Sasha I'm a principal genetic
counselor at guys and Saint Thomas's
hospital and a PhD student at the genome
campus genetic counseling is a job where
we help people with genetic conditions
to understand why they've happened and
why they might affect other people in
the family it's a really important job
because it helps people to deal with the
impact of having a genetic condition and
understanding it so that they can make
the best decisions to help them and
their families
on a typical day before you see a
patient it's really important to make
sure that you've prepared to see that
patient and that means that I'll go and
do research into the condition that the
patient has been referred for genetic
research changes all the time and there
might be things that we now know about a
condition that we hadn't known
previously
it's really crucial when I first meet a
patient that I ask them why they're
there and what their questions are and
that's because everybody's really
different and everybody has very
different understanding about genetics
and the causes of genetic conditions
once I understand a little bit more
about where people are coming from it
helps me to explain the genetic
information and answer any questions
they have and do that in a way that is
appropriate for them based on their
faith based on their culture based on
their family and the situation that
they're in at that moment
being a genetic counselor has been
really exciting for me because I've been
able to travel around the country and
also outside of the country so I worked
for a short time as a genetic counselor
in Johannesburg because I was really
interested in knowing about how a
completely different society and
Community use genetic counseling and how
it works for the people there I've also
worked in Manchester in the UK and in
London and also I visit support groups
schools groups and Faith groups talking
about genetics as well
in order to become a genetic counselor
it's really important to have a science
background and a caring background so I
started school really interested in
science so most of my background is a
science background I did biology in my
undergraduate and I did science
communication but my work in Charities
also meant that I had caring experience
and therefore I was able to do a masters
in genetic counseling and that's how I
became a genetic counselor ever since I
was really little I was always
curious about how things work and I
think that's where my interest in
science comes from but also my
background was just really colorful and
really vibrant I'm from a really Lively
part of East London and so I was really
exposed from an early age to lots of
different cultures lots of different
types of food lots of different ways of
living so I think when I look at what I
do now it kind of makes sense
I do really love my job and no two days
are the same sometimes it is really hard
and people do receive really sad news
but on the flip side sometimes people
receive really good news and I feel
really really privileged to be the
person who's able to tell somebody the
most amazing news of their life
[Music]